take a look at these pictures that Stu
Peters posted this is crazy stuff right
here we got this tweet Stu Peter says
Ohio this is what's happening to cars
after driving through spurts of rain 70
plus miles Southeast of the East
Palestine incident yeah that's like
relatively close to where we are I think
that's like where you are comfortably
close to work uncomfortably take a look
at these pictures
so okay all right maybe this is nothing
I don't want to you know it's a tweet
saying this is it's it's just people
posting on the internet we don't know
that it's true but look at these photos
they're they're covered in I don't know
man it looks like salt almost like look
at this these streaks yeah it does look
like it looks like someone drove their
car through like New England right after
yeah after like the salt but it looks
like it looks like the paint even like
kind of flaked off or something
especially here like what is this that's
weird residue yeah I mean weird residue
there was no way to avoid that that
cloud was black there was definitely
residue falling back to earth right it's
just the question of is this residue
toxic
it's going to be in like 10 years you're
going to be watching YouTube and you're
gonna be watching you know Tim cast iron
really old people I'm just kidding I'll
be 47 so I won't sound like that but
then all of a sudden ads gonna play and
it's like did you live within 200 miles
of East Palestine Ohio yep you may and
are you suffering from breathing
problems you may be entitled to a large
cash settlement contact the law firm of
non-logic Hodgkin's lymphoma no yeah I
said this yes but one of the Hazmat
responders has seen said everyone should
go get their health evaluated right now
so they have a base point to to uh track
what happens next to their bodies
because you don't know what's going to
happen so having a basic physical right
now will be able to potentially help you
in a class action lawsuit he didn't say
that part I did but you know if you
can't tell what's wrong with you it'd be
easy for a company to be like oh well
how do we know you didn't already have
markers for leukemia
hmm apparently people were saying like
Aaron Brockovich was was saying
something
oh yeah yeah Aaron Aaron Brockovich is
speaking up now asking Biden to step up
as people fall sick at animals dropped
dead after Ohio trained derailment
could this be what Knox uh Biden out of
of the race maybe a failure to respond
to an obvious dis like massive
potentially the worst disaster chemical
spill in this country yeah I mean he's
already not he's already extremely
unpopular I don't see why it couldn't be
a situation where you know people are
have a significant turn against the
administration he's he's not the plot of
The West Wing they're like one of the
seasons that like Republican is doing
well in the race and then there's a
factory fire or something and he just
can never recover from it I could be
misremembering this I was never never a
West Wing fan you're not a political
nerd well I mean um there's one I can't
do episodic TV it's I just don't have
the patience um but yeah I mean I don't
know but the fact that Aaron Brock which
is is making remarks you know right yeah
they made a movie about her oh yeah with
Julia Roberts yeah and she I mean that
she did uh you know she you did win the
case I don't remember the details of the
case but yeah I was like chromium in the
water or something it was a big finding
so how would Biden respond to this to
handle it you know we're 10 days out I
don't feel like he's given a strong
response to it is there any way for us
not to look at him and be like why did
we not have us I mean I've I've heard
maybe you can speak to this more that uh
the Red Cross isn't doesn't really have
a strong presence in the area that
there's not a lot of information that
people are having problems in the
government you know the government
agencies are doing nothing I've probably
heard about the same as you but it seems
like that there is no response of any
kind from any level literally nothing
and I've even seen unsubstantiated but
journalists are being arrested that are
trying to get one at least and I always
I always liked it but that was that was
at a press conference yeah and
apparently he was just being noisy and
he was like doing his live reports they
tend to do but I mean I just I always
can't help but think what would happen
if the former guy this happened
underneath him this would be world
ending news if this happened oh yeah
this was would be the worst possible
thing it doesn't matter how it happened
it would be his fault so now that I mean
because it's binding it just doesn't you
know I heard I heard Biden did it I mean
that's the I heard the same thing yeah
easy to point the finger right it's
clearly his fault he's so obsessed with
trains it does seem like something he'd
do yeah I know a guy and his brother
knows one of the people who lives just
outside of the Town whose friend lived
nearby he said he saw a bud all right
right there good enough for me if it's
good enough for them why isn't it good
enough right exactly absolutely good
enough so uh someone close to the Biden
administration office
says that Joe Biden personally derailed
the Train the person close to the office
was the homeless guy in the alley but he
was physically close to his office so
I'm telling you the truth that's the
narrative that's how they play those
games man yeah yeah but no in all
seriousness I don't think and the Biden
Administration came out and just said
the air was safe
that's about it and now there's dead
fish washing up in streams there's uh
one guy who breeds foxes as they're all
sick and the chickens are dead yeah the
chicken's being dead that crossed the
line
is going to be like no that's just a
coincidence we said the air was safe
everything's okay like they're just
gonna continue to try to sidestep this
which is crazy what would you do I'd
leave and and we've even talked about
leaving here now we're we're down uh
down uh wind from the incident we're not
in the direct water impacted area
because we're in the the Panhandle but
still people are saying like hey look
man they're they're someone super
chatted just now saying looks like a
storm is going to come through and those
storm patterns they move Eastward which
means we could get rained on with this
stuff yeah so what should we do should
we lock up the chickens keep them safe
and protected and keep them out of the
rain that rain comes through it could
kill the chicken they'll generally keep
the chickens out of the lock and keep
the chickens in the coop this is tough
because if that stuff does come through
the rain and it rains here it's going to
go in the ground and there's nothing we
can do it will be in the ground
everywhere and there's no way to protect
the chickens other than building a
sealed airtight you know hyperbaric
chamber that we Pump Air and food into
to keep them safe and that's just
because they're little chickens you know
we'll still be breathing in all the
garbage and getting sick
yeah I think I think you know the
challenge for you uh
delegate is that what is that is that
what I say is it to say delegate like
yeah that would work okay uh is
um I mean your your county is much
closer you're in the water radius I mean
what do you do how do you what what do
you do I I've had a lot of people asking
that question and this is my least
favorite answer to give to that question
is I don't know I have to sit here and
wait for the information to be drip fed
to me I'm praying to God that the
information that I'm getting is accurate
or at the very least you know at the
very least accurate best case it's it's
helpful or you know it will provide a
little bit of of comfort but I don't
know what we can do we're just at the
mercy of this this extremely unnatural
event it's possibly what I can't think
of any worse man-made natural man-made
chemical disaster that's happened in on
American soil so we just have to sit
here and effectively take it and all I
have to do is you know I have to trust
the science trust the experts you know
this is this this speaks to how badly
trust has been damaged in the uh in in
the government generally I mean I'm a
Libertarian leaning kind of dude anyways
so I don't generally trust the
government but when you've got your
average people that have spent two years
dealing with all the pandemic
inconsistencies we'll call it between
you know about the the treatments and
what the best practices are it's been so
back and forth and so erratic and so
um just so so inconsistent you can't
expect people to look at the government
and be like oh yeah I feel good about
the information that I'm getting and I
feel confident that you're telling me
that this isn't going to be a problem
and I believe you I don't think that
there are a lot of people that feel that
way anymore I think it's telling that
Biden has not publicly addressed the
situation education obviously Americans
are concerned about it if it really is
like things are okay then have him come
out and make a statement about it have
Kamala come out and say make a statement
about it I mean we got we got a super
chat from Brandon angel said my buddy
lives in Wellsville Ohio he's 20 miles
out from the incident he was told not to
drink the water anymore he's been having
headaches chest pain and feeling sick
sick since it happened I believe an
imageless profile super chatting a live
show on the internet more than the Biden
Administration on this one when a
stranger someone I've never met comments
and says a guy I know is sick I believe
it because I just I saw a video of dead
chickens and so when the bite
Administration comes out and says
whatever they want to say you know you
know what I would say to people
here's my advice
we're close enough
to the to the the the the wind to the
air that if a storm rolls through this
stuff could hit us as well
so the only thing I'd say is you can see
the black smoke
do you trust the media don't know
do you trust the government probably not
so then make the decision for yourself
and that might mean you may decide to
evacuate that may mean you make less
money that may mean you struggle to find
somewhere to go and wait it out safely
for what how long a month
or
you decide to stay
and you may make the wrong decision me
personally we're actually looking at
maybe you know just doing rescheduling
the show and maybe going down somewhere
for a few weeks because we don't want to
get caught up in a storm that might roll
through but then what we got the
chickens here anyway not every person
can leave so what just the IRL crew
leaves that's tough man that's a tough
decision so my advice to people who live
in the area is if you can get out get
out
and figure it out if you can that's my
advice I'm not saying you should take it
I'm just saying if I were you and I
lived directly in the water basin of
impacted area yeah I'd probably buy a
bunch of water right now fill up as much
water as I can and even now it may be
too late because this has been going on
for what to a week and a half now yeah
and maybe too late it's been a week and
a half of this yeah
that's kind of worrying and this is what
really causes my heart to hurt so much
as I think about the places that I've
been in West Virginia through work or
anything political or otherwise and I've
seen the hills I've seen the haulers I
know the people that are there they've
been there for Generations they're not
going anywhere anytime soon it doesn't
matter if nuclear bombs are going off
but they just have to sit there and have
this happen to them and they're they'll
be lucky if they even get information
that's semi-accurate from any agency any
level of any government it does not
matter that it's just going to sit there
and happen to them if it's going to rain
on them and it's going to ruin their
life and they can't do a thing about it
we normally save super chats at the end
but we've got a bunch of them that are
coming that I think are good and
definitely fact check but Tyler B says
the rain is hydrochloric acid I don't
know if that's true but he says Vinyl
chloride Burns releasing hydrogen
chloride which bonds the water vapor in
the clouds stay out of the rain at all
costs now I don't know if that's true
you want to look that up I do know that
they said the vinyl chloride will burn
creating hydrogen chloride and go up in
the air that's something they reported
in the press and that makes sense the
hydrogen would bond with water vapor the
uh well I have this from something about
earlier today the EPA says that because
they burn the vinyl chloride there is no
threat of the hydrochloride like
hydrochloric acid yeah they said there's
not there's not an issue but somehow I
just don't believe these people say you
know yeah actually a tip that
something's uh something is a mess
I'm looking it up
because I think this is really important
right now man I mean especially for me
because you know we're here acid rain
hey take a look at this from uh USGS the
U.S Geological Survey
acid rain uh and then one of the things
that was in the let's let's uh what are
we looking for uh here we go
hydrogen chloride which converts to
hydrochloric acid well that's strange
this says uh
acid deposition commonly called acid
rain is a term applied to all forms of
atmospheric atmospheric deposition of
acidic substances rain snow fog acidic
dry particulates aerosols and acid
forming gases water in the atmosphere
reacts with certain atmospheric gases to
become acidic for example water reacts
with carbon dioxide in the atmosphere to
produce a solution with a pH of about
5.6 gases that produce acids in the
presence of water in the atmosphere
include carbon dioxide oxides of sulfur
and nitrogen and hydrogen chloride which
converts to hydrochloric acid and
they're saying there's no risk we burned
it all off and you're good to go don't
even worry about it
they're burning the vinyl chloride
creating hydrogen chloride going into
the atmosphere which the
usgs.gov literally says can convert into
hydrochloric acid and produce acid rain
so was this was this like a local police
decision to burn this it's Norfolk
Southern they worked with the Ohio EPA
or uh they're the train operator and
they're like the best way or best bet to
prevent this thing exploding and sending
shrapnels was to have a controlled burn
there's there's a couple people in the
chat in the chat that are saying that
they've got family that are sick or that
they're feeling sick that are in the
area and this is so the other part of
this EPA update that I used in uh and
updated on the story today is that uh
again I'm just gonna read directly on
the evening of February 13th the US EPA
discontinued air monitoring for
phosphagine and hydrochloride Community
air monitoring wait wait wait wait read
that one more time on the evening of
February 13th the U.S EPA discontinued
air monitoring for phosphagine and
hydrogen chloride Community air
monitoring so there's saying you're good
you can see here we stopped tracking it
they're saying after the fire was
extinguished on February 8th the threat
of vinyl chloride fire producing
phosphagine or hydrogen chloride no
longer exists
maybe they say you're good Tim don't
leave DJ says stay every time we talk
about this I can hear Luke gradkowski
screaming all the way from Florida about
the air on 9 11. yeah the EPA said it
was safe but it's a huge Scandal yeah
Jon Stewart goes on TV and before
Congress all the time they came out and
said the air was safe to breathe get to
work and now all of these First
Responders their lungs are Scar Tissue
cancers they're dying that's some of the
most that's some of the darkest stuff
ever man I mean if you can like it's not
a bad idea to the I know everyone's
gonna have a feeling about masking but
now is the time to pull out that 3M mask
that you know the big ones right there
right but how interesting is it that now
you have a bunch of people who seem
asking as you know a form of Oppression
by the government which I totally think
is fair but this is actually the time
when we needed it yeah this is the time
where you need like but that you know
yeah this isn't like where a t-shirt's
gonna work you need like serious I
already said people should get their
significant others uh gas masks for
Valentine's Day all right that is true
so I just want to wrap this this this
part of it by saying
if if I was in anywhere near this I'd be
calling a relative and being like can we
come stay with you for a little bit yeah
maybe maybe just let the rains come in
give it a couple weeks I don't know
maybe it's too difficult I get it
whatever for everybody else get water
like even if you're not in the area you
should have some storage water in your
house and food yeah but think about this
it could be two weeks or three weeks or
four where you decide to go on a
vacation go visit relatives a couple
States over
but maybe if you stay and these
chemicals are killing chickens it could
be a lifetime of cancer or disease I'm
not saying I know for sure I'm not a
doctor you know it so it's hard I'm just
distrusting of the official government
statement but maybe they're not wrong I
just would personally not believe they
were right thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time